[Applause]
[Music]
but nice see your garden hose
my physical links and ow sem oooooh ho
brook and horticulture roma music and libie
my buddy stuff let my vision canopy
tour
around him the oven with grill
oh we well nice but that ran  on and
try to join sick join
my sweet and rich our will ever had
inside
him and you we read
people dancing moving and the worms
am politics long sleeves and audience and
[Music]
its little
not our trip
what do I hear baby team and  and the
endo sensei so with i wanted so pure they
should like a stone for physical
suffering and our fish and color devil city
also seemed a week to do my new
color and this physical were not allowed to bangs
like the luxury in bed
[Music]